Land und
[Musik]
prcht schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus na und was geht dir heute
durch den Kopf ehrlich gesagt etwas
worüber ich schon längere Zeit mal mit
dir sprechen wollte wir haben auch immer
wieder als Thema gehabt wir beide in
ganz ganz vielen verschiedenen Facetten
dieses riesige Thema Migration und dann
aber verknüpft mit dem was demografisch
auf Deutschland zukommt und ich habe das
Gefühl da man spürt an jeder Ecke so
eine riesige Ratlosigkeit also auf der
einen Seite sagt mir jeden zweiten Abend
jemand in der Sendung deutschland
braucht eine drastische Reduktion von
Zuwanderung und zwar schnellm und
zugleich bedroht der Personalmangel die
Infrastruktur des Landes ja also ich
kenne nur die andere Seite der Medaille
also wenn ich in der Wirtschaft
unterwegs bin dann höre ich immer so
zahlen so zwischen 400.000 und 1
Millionen Migranten pro Jahr ja
Arbeitsmigranten bräuchten wir um die
Lücken aufzufüllen die jetzt und
demnächst durch die Boomer Generation
wenn die in Rente gehen gerissen werden
genau so und das ist natürlich etwas das
kannst du im Moment politisch keinem
vermitteln und dieser Widerspruch der
heißt gerade das Land und dann erlebt
man immer so verzweifelte Versuche dann
wird dann gesagt ja also wenn man die
Leute dann in die Enge treibt und sagt
das läuft alles völlig unkontrolliert
und auf Lampedusa kommen zum Teil 50 60
Boote am Tag an und so weiter dann sagen
sie irgendwann wenn es gar nicht mehr
anders geht und du weiter insistierst
und fragst was machenchen wir den dann
mit den Leuten wie kriegen wir die in
den Arbeitsmarkt und wie kriegen wir die
wieder zurück die keinen Anspruch auf
Asyl und so weiter haben dann merkst du
häufig den Versuch der Umetikettierung
sagt man plötzlich ganz schnell ja aber
wissen Sie wir brauchen ja auch
Fachkräfte und es ist alles so hilflos
und so wenig
planmäßig dass ich mich manchmal Frage
wo soll das eigentlich bitte schon enden
und wenn Du und das war mein Gedanke
heute ich würde gerne mal mit dir
Richard über sozusagen die Frage reden
möglichst differenziert was ist
eigentlich gut an Migration was ist
notwendig und was ist gleichzeitig auch
schlecht an migration ja das ist eine
schöne Frage das ist eine schöne frage
weil ich finde den Begriff planmäßige
Migration eigentlich schon fast sowas
wie ein Widerspruch in sich richtig weil
der Grund
das ist ja nicht so dass dass sich Leute
sagen in Deutschland fehlen im
Gastrobereich 200 oder 300 000 Menschen
da habe ich doch mal Lust zu arbeiten
deswegen verlasse ich jetzt Guinea also
das Motiv sein Land zu zu verlassen ist
ja nicht als dringend gebrauchte
Arbeitskraft äh in einer bestimmten
Sparte in einem dafür pas den Land zu
landen mhm also Migration ist jetzt von
den Ursachen für Migration und von den
von den Migrationsströmen her ja nie
planmäßig es gibt einen berühmten alten
Satz von Karl Marx der gesagt hat die
Menschenströme folgen den Kapitalströmen
ja also da wo Wohlstand ist ja da da
wollen die Menschen hin so und das ist
erstmal ganz natürlich ich glaube fast
jeder Mensch möchte lieber dahin wo
Wohlstand ist als da wo Armut oder gar
wo Hunger herrscht und das heißt also
die Motivation warum es Migranten gibt
hat nichts mit der Frage zu tun die wir
hier stellen nämlich wo kriegen wir
qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte und übrigens
auch unqualifizierte Arbeitskräfte her
deswegen habe ich mich immer so
gewundert dass die Diskussion häufig
politisch so geführt wird dass man sagt
ja wir brauchen qualifizierte
Zuwanderung genau das ist irreführend
das ist deswegen irreführend weil
Deutschland fehlen nicht nur
IT-Spezialisten sondern Deutschland
fehlen im ganz großen Spiel Leute auf
dem Bau fehlen Leute in der Gastronomie
ja in der in der industriellen Fertigung
flughen und da gibt es viele viele genau
am Flughafen das sind gibt's viele
Beschäftigungsverhältnisse da kannst du
gerade niemand gebrauchen der
hochqualifiziert ist weil der wird das
nicht machen sondern wir brauchen ja
nicht nur Fachkräfte sondern wir
brauchen ganz allgemein Arbeitskräfte
und zwar zu 100ertausenden in jedem Jahr
neu und jetzt haben wir sozusagen unsere
Bedarfssituation auf der einen Seite und
wir haben die Ursachen und Gründe warum
Menschen flüchten fliehen und zu uns
wollen auf der anderen Seite und die
beiden Dinge haben erst einmal fast
nichts miteinander zu tun genau aber
weißt du was Richard vielleicht
vielleicht fangen wir mal ganz vorne an
also vielleicht fangen wir mal bei
diesem demographischen Faktor an ich
habe manchmal das Gefühl wir haben immer
noch nicht richtig verinnerlicht und
richtig verstanden was das eigentlich
für eine Welt ist und ehrlich gesagt
verdränge ich das auch und ich weiß ich
werde Teil dieses Problems wenn man so
will sein oder dieser
Situation wir haben noch nicht richtig
verstanden was da eigentlich auf uns
zukommt der demographisch Faktor also
wenn man sich mal diese berühmten
altersbäume mal anschaut schaust dir das
mal vor 100 Jahren an dann war das eine
Pyramide das heißt du hast unten ein
ganz ganz breites Fundament sehr viele
junge Menschen und dann verjüngt sich
das nach oben hin ja weil mit Z mit dem
Alter sterben die Leute einfach langsam
weg wenn du dir das heute anschaust um
es jetzt ganz arg verkürzt und schon wie
soll man sagen ein bisschen zugespitzt
zu sagen hast du heute keine Tanne mehr
da stehen dann du hast eine Zwiebel die
Zwiebel wird nach oben ne ganz schön
dick weil wir ja mit Hilfe der
zaubermedizin der Zukunft jetzt erwarten
alle deutlich älter zu werden als die
Generation unserer Eltern und unserer
Großeltern das kommt ja auch noch dazu
also wir haben wir einmal die die
medizinische Versorgung und die
Alterserwartung und den demografischen
Faktor genau und wenn du Hinblick auf
unsere Sozialsysteme haben wir noch ganz
viel mehr andere Probleme z.B dass die
Leute deutlich weniger arbeiten und
deswegen haben wir ein weniger einzahlen
oder es kommt dazu dass sie nicht mehr
wie in Adenauer Zeiten so im
Durchschnitt mit 17 18 in den
Arbeitsmarkt kamen ja sondern dadurch
dass so viele studieren erst mit Mitte
oder Ende 20 richtig sind auch alles
Jahre in denen nicht genau Zeit wird
deswegen meine ich differenziert und es
ist sehr komplex und wenn man da mal
einsteigt dann wird's aber auch wirklich
interessant und ich habe das Gefühl wir
diskutieren so häufig einfach um die
Fakten herum wenn du noch mal Demografie
praktisch alle Industrieländer auf der
Welt haben eine Geburtenrate deutlich
unter
zwei also ich glaube 100 oder 110
Staaten auf der Welt so habe ich es im
Kopf haben eine Geburtenrate unter zwei
Reproduktion das bedeutet das reicht
nicht um eine Bevölkerung stabil zu
halten ne ich glaub also entweder auf
Zuzug angewiesen oder die
Wirtschaftsleistung schrumpft richtig
und über die zweite Alternative wollen
wir nicht ernsthaft nachdenken ich habe
zwar schon Leute getroffen die gesagt
haben ja ist es halt so dann sind wir
ein ein powerland mit 65 Millionen so ja
nee dann vor allen werden erstmal ganz
ganz viele Betriebe zuug Grunde gehen
das das meine ich also das powerland mit
65 Millionen a aus aus Mangel an an
Arbeitskräften das wäre ein Rückbau will
nur noch mal die die die Zahlen die
niedrigste Geburtenrate glaube ich in in
der sogenannten westlichen Welt ja in
hochentwickelten Industrieländern
Südkorea
0,88 haben wir schon mal drüber
gesprochen dass in in Südkorea die
Regierung mittlerweile sagt aber bitte
nicht so viel an einem Abend in der
Woche ist so eine offizielle
regierungsempfehlung muss bitte um 18
Uhr im Büro das Licht ausgehen dann geht
ihr bitte nach Hause und dann macht ihr
bitte nach dem Abendessen wieder das
Licht aus und dann tut ihr bitte das
wasaner zu tun hat genau close your eyes
and think of Korea genau vermehrt geht
hin und vermehret euch was eigentlich
ein schönes Konzept ist aber
funktioniert nicht die Leute gehen das
nicht mit Italien Spanien
1,28 also bei 1,3 ungefähr Kanada und
auch sogar die Vereinigten Arabischen
Emirate liegen bei 1,46 und Deutschland
liegt glaube ich irgendwo im Mittelfeld
bei 1,58 also knapp 1,6 kann man sagen
das heißt das reicht hinten und vorne
nicht du bräuchtest glaube ich um das
stabil zu halten ungefähr 2,3 und dann
hast du nur sozusagen das was da einfach
schon ist erhalten schlicht und
ergreifend das ist auf der einen Seite
die Situation und dann geht man immer
und sagt ja gut das können wir dann ja
mit Automation lösen da können wir dann
Servicepersonal in Gaststätten und das
siehst du ja auch immer mehr ne bestell
Apps
austeilroboter stadtkassiererinen
automatisierte Großküchen hinter den
Kulissen also der größte Teil der
Digitalisierung in Hotellerie und
Gastwirtschaft und so weiter findet ja
hinter den Kulissen statt richtig das
ist das was man gar nicht sieht genau
genau und und wenn du dann aber mal
genau hinguckst also in Wahrheit glaube
ich machen wir uns auch da überhaupt
dreht sich finde ich in dieser Folge
wenn wir es wen es gut hinkriegen ganz
viel darum wie wir uns selber in die
Tasche lügen also es gibt in Wahrheit
wenige Anwendungsfälle in denen solche
Lösungen wirklich
gutesespal oder Handwerker
ersetzen immer in vielen Bereichen ja in
der Pflege nicht also wenn wir nach wie
vor wahnsinnig viel mehr Menschen
brauchen als jetzt aber es gibt durchaus
Bereiche ne also im Bereich der
geistigen Routinearbeit und so weiter
bin ich ganz ganz sicher dass wir
zukünftig mit weniger Personal auskommen
nur es dauert lange mhmau also es kann
ja sein dass unsere unsere Verwaltungen
in 20 Jahren voll automatisiert sind der
Hauptgrund warum sie es nicht sind ist
weil sie es nicht wollen der menschliche
Faktor der Widerstand die Angst
Arbeitslose zu produzieren da gibt's ja
tausend Gründe warum das was rein
technisch geht in der Realität dann doch
nicht funktioniert aber es wird
irgendwann wird es dazu kommen aber du
hast gleichzeitig mit dem anderen Recht
selbst wenn das so ist ja dass einige
vielleicht sogar Millionen
Beschäftigungsverhältnisse die wir heute
haben in 10 20 Jahren äh automatisiert
sind in anderen Bereichen wird der
Bedarf wachsen gerade weil wir ja so alt
werden ja also Pflege da wird noch das
der Bedarf ja sich verdoppeln oder
verdreifachen oder vervierfachen auch im
ganzen Gesundheitssystem wird immer mehr
und mehr Personal gebraucht werden das
heißt also die die Automatisierung
strukturiert zwar den Arbeitsmarkt um
führt aber am Ende nicht dazu dass
unterm Strich weniger Leute gebraucht
werden so und der Roboter der uns beide
dann sanft und liebevoll irgendwann
wäscht ich kann mir den nicht vorstellen
also ich ich fürchte wir werden auch da
weiter auf Menschen angewiesen sein so
und das und das jetzt noch mal die
nächste Ebene kontrastiert natürlich
unglaublich hart ich habe am am
Wochenende erinnerst du dich in einer
der letzten Folgen haben wir gesprochen
über diese junge Frau ich glaube dies
Video mittlerweile 50 Millionen mal
geteilt nur bei tiktok diese junge Frau
die sagte sie hat keine Zeit mehr für
ihre Freunde und und so weiter und sie
muss eigentlich nur arbeiten die dann
für viele sozusagen wieder der der Beleg
dafür war wie unfassbar faul und
gemütlich diese Generation Z ist
interessante war an dem Punkt ich frage
mich auch nachdem ich jetzt ein
Interview mit Bill Gates am Wochenende
gelesen habe der sagte Freunde stellt
euch drauf ein wir werden in eineer
Gesellschaft gehen da wird die vier Tage
Woche selbstverständlich sein und das
Interessante ist diese junge Frau ich
hab mir das noch mal angesehen die ist
sich darüber im Klaren dass sie dafür
kritisiert werden wird die sagt ich ich
ich wirke wahrscheinlich total
dramatisch und ich nerve euch und gehe
auch richtig auf den Keks ja aber diese
Regelarbeitszeit macht mich fertig und
ob wir das jetzt gut finden oder nicht
diese Generation hat eine andere
Vorstellung vom Leben die hat eine
andere Perspektive auf das Leben ja und
das kriegst du auch nicht zurückgedreht
ja ja und ich meine also hinzugehen und
zu sagen ich will ein gutes Leben haben
ich will ein glückliches Leben haben ich
will was Sinnvolles
machen ich will nicht wie meine Eltern
keine Zeit für ihre Kinder haben ich
will beides ich will beruflich
erfolgreich sein ich möchte aber auch
ein guter Vater sein und eine gute
Mutter und genug Zeit haben und ich muss
will ganz viel Zeit für meine Freunde
haben weil das ist wichtig für mich und
so das alles sind gute und völlig
nachvollziehbare Ziele und deswegen wird
es auch in der Tat so kommen dass wir im
Durchschnitt weniger arbeiten und das
ist auch deswegen logisch weil das ist
seit der industriellen Revolution der
ersten ja im 18 Jahrhundert W man noch
bis zu 80 Stunden in der Woche
gearbeitet hat und dann guck wo wir
heute gelandet sind dann ist das
Arbeiten immer weniger geworden und das
wird es dauerhaft auch richtig in
welchem Tempo ist eine andere Frage ja
und im Grunde genommen leben ja die
Menschen der jüngeren Generation schon
so als ob ja im Modus das als ob als ob
die
Automatisierung bereits einen sehr
erheblichen Teil jener Berufe einfachen
Berufe für die man jetzt noch Menschen
braucht als ob das bereits funktionieren
würde das heißt also sie leben von ihrem
mindset 20 Jahre weiter als die
gegenwärtige ökonomische Situation ist
und ich glaube das ist der große GAP den
wir heute haben zwischen den
Bedürfnissen zwischen der Haltung
jüngerer Menschen zur Arbeit die ich
durchaus positiv finde und der
ökonomischen Situation die einfach noch
nicht soweit ist ja genau und da
verändert sich auch deswegen ist schon
richtig was du da anprichst mindset sagt
man heutzutage ja die die Mentalität die
Haltung ja ich meine die deutschen
Träumen ich spitze es jetzt mal zu von
der vier Tage Woche und vom Beamtentum
so beschreiben das auch die Leute von
weiß und verweisen auf Studien aus aus
England beispielsweise wo du sehen
kannst in einzelnen Unternehmen vier
Tage Woche auch in im im Mutterland des
Kapitalismus in den USA in Kalifornien
gibt es die ersten Firmen die die vier
Tage Woche anbieten und sehe da die
große Überraschung und da siehst du wo
der Zeitgeist hingeht es ist auf jeden
Fall nicht so dass die Leute
zwangsläufig unproduktiver sind dass am
Ende weniger dabei herauskommt äh
sondern offensichtlich
schlägt man sonst an so einem
klassischen alten Arbeitsplatz der
Vergangenheit auch teilweise die Zeit
tot und wenn die Leute das Gefühl haben
es lohnt sich ein bisschen heftiger
reinzuhauen und dafür früher fertig zu
sein dann tun sie das auch genau aber
das geht nicht in ein Berufen ne also
das geht in dem berufen wo die Arbeit
auch ein bisschen Spaß macht oder wo wo
man sagt ja das ist jetzt irgendwie
Selbstverwirklichung od wo der
Pflichtanteil nicht so hoch ist also es
gibt bestimmte Bereiche in denen sich
die vier Tage Woche sicher durchsetzen
wird nämlich da wo man darauf angewiesen
ist dass die diese quasi gesparte und
gesammelte Energie ja dann anschließend
sich produktiv in der Arbeit umsetzen
kann genau deswegen finde ich es mal
wichtig und auch gut so die die großen
Linien mal aufzumalen und wenn du über
Migration sprichst auch mal klar
zumachen was da im Hintergrund noch
läuft ne die Demografie ist das eine
Thema haben wir gerade schon abgehakt
das zweite Thema bei dem wir gerade sind
ist die große Frage wie verändert sich
unser Verhältnis zur Arbeit ja der
Zeitgeist gib noch so eine interessante
Studie aus aus England 43% der Briten
sagen heute 43% fast die Hälfte dass es
gut wäre wenn Arbeit keine so große
Rolle mehr in unserem Leben spielen
würde 1981 das ist jetzt nicht so
unendlich lange her stimmt dieser
Aussage noch 26% zu in Deutschland
übrigens ähnlich in Deutschland Stimmen
sogar 45% der Befragten mittlerweile
dieser Aussage zu 1980 waren es noch 30%
das heißt du siehst da verschiebt sich
was in der Wahrnehmung und ob uns das
jetzt gefällt oder nicht ja aber das ist
das was gerade in den Köpfen passiert
und das heißt immer weniger Menschen
denken dass die Arbeit über der Freizeit
stehen sollte und das harte Arbeits
zwangsläufig zum Erfolg führt das
Erleben die auch übrigens ja oder dass
keine Arbeit Menschen faul macht das
glauben die nicht sondern die sagen nö
neö neö neö euer haben wir schon mal
drüber geredet euer aufstiegsversprechen
funktioniert ja nicht mehr so richtig
ich ich ich Schufte ich haue richtig
rein kenne viele junge Leute die sich
sehr sehr anstrengen die trotzdem das
Gefühl haben Freunde euer Modell ist am
Ende angelangt weil funktioniert für
mich nicht mehr ich
kann und der materielle Anreiz auch
vielleicht auch im Leben gleichsweise
vergleichsweise mit der
wirtschaftswundergeneration und so
weiter an Bedeutung verloren hat ich
meine ich habe ja mal ein dickes Buch
geschrieben ne Freiheit für alle dass
ich mit diesem Wechsel von der
Arbeitsgesellschaft wie wir sie kannten
hin zur sinngesellschaft beschäftigt was
mich jetzt interessiert ja welche Rolle
und das ist ein Thema mit dem ich mich
nicht beschäftigt habe oder kaum welche
Rolle spielt Migration jetzt darin ja
das ist halt sozusagen dann die also ich
ich finde es wichtig diesen Hintergrund
mal zu verstehen ja dass dass der der
Hintergrund vor dem diese Debatte auch
um die Frage wie viel Migration brauchen
wir wie viel Migration ist nötig wie
viel Migration ist dann irgendwann zu
viel was wie können wir das irgendwie
regeln deutschland braucht in den
kommenden 20 Jahren massive Zuwanderung
wenn wir schweren wirtschaftlichen
Schaden abwenden wollen es gibt heute
fast 2 Millionen offene Stellen bis
2035 sagen Leute die sich damit
auskennen werden fünf Millionen
Beschäftigte mehr in Rente gehen als
junge Beschäftigte Nachkommen das heißt
deutschland braucht selbst bei einer
konservativen Rechnung mindestens eine
halbe Million zusätzliche Arbeitskräfte
aus dem Ausland das heißt eine
Zuwanderung von knapp einer Millionen
Menschen pro Jahr um nur die Lücke die
die Babyboomer hinterlassen zu füllen
dies alles muss man im Hinterkopf haben
wenn man dann so so diese diese sehr
populistische Stimme hört so jetzt es
reicht und so es erinert der ja fast
dann diese das Boot ist voll Diskussion
die wir mal hatten
ähm selbst
konservative sagen dir dann auch abseits
der Fernsehkamera pass auf also ich kann
das gerade so offen nicht sagen aber
Migration und ich kann das auch
politisch nicht wirklich vermitteln aber
wir müssen den Leuten eigentlich sagen
wir brauchen mindestens 400.000 Leute
jedes Jahr in Zukunft in Deutschland das
bedeutet dass du wenn du es ganz also
400.000 Leute zusätzlich die aus dem
Ausland die müssen 400.000 Leute müssen
kommen und die sagen aber um 400.000
Leute irgendwie in den Arbeitsmarkt zu
kriegen brauchst du eigentlich
800.000 weil die arbeiten ja nicht alle
sofort ne und manche sind minderjährig
und manche bringen die Menschen bringen
ja ihr Leben mit ist ja nicht so dass
einfach jemand kommt und sagt und da bin
ich und ich bin Fachkraft xy und wo
geht's bitteschön in den deutschen
Arbeitsmarkt so funktioniert ja das
Leben nicht ne das hab ich vorhin gesagt
also der Sinn von Migration aus der
Sicht derjenigen die migrieren wir reden
also jetzt über politisch Verfolgte über
Kriegsflüchtlinge aber auch über
Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge besteht ja nicht
darin die
Probleme des Arbeitsmarktes in
Deutschland zu lösen das ist nicht ihre
Motivation aber wenn du mal anfängst
dich mit dem mit der mit der Motivation
zu beschäftigen und vielleicht ist das
sozusagen wenn wir auch wollen auch
versuchen ein ein ein bisschen nicht zu
einer Lösung zu kommen aber zumindest
sagen wir mal die Eindimensionalität ein
bisschen aus der Diskussion rausnehmen
genau ich hatte zwei sehr interessante
wie soll man sagen erleb beim beim beim
Lesen von Gesprächen und und Interviews
in den letzten Wochen die mich wirklich
ins Nachdenken gebracht haben das eine
war ein sehr bekannter
Migrationsforscher der sagte bitte hört
doch mal auf euch ständig was
vorzumachen die Hauptmotivation der
meisten Menschen sind rein
wirtschaftliche Gründe die kommen
schlicht weil sie ein besseres Leben
haben wollen ganz einfach genau wobei
man noch mal unterscheiden müsste
zwischen denjenigen die quasi aus
den semiariden Gebiet südlich der Sahara
stammen wo ja sehr viele Flüchtlinge
herkommen die also sehen einfach sie
haben keine Lebensperspektive mehr ja
also unter anderem durch den Klimawandel
und so weiter so und das ist ja die
Frage also wenn man sagt die kommen um
ein besseres Leben zu haben dann hört
sich das ein bisschen nach Luxus an nee
das meine ich natürlich nicht muss
natürlich mal unterscheiden es gibt
Leute die kommen aus Ländern die sind
überhaupt nicht vom Hungertod bedroht
die kommen aus aus halbwegs
funktionierenden Staaten und es gibt
Leute es gibt Leute die aus einem Land
kommen wo sie absolut gar keine Ernst
nebende Zukunftsperspektive in keiner
Form irgendwo haben und es gibt Leute
die unmittelbar mit ihren Familien vom
Hungertod bedroht sind die fallen ja
alle unter einen einzigen Begriff
Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge und das ist aber
alles verschiedene Schicksal alles
verschiedene Schicksale wofür ich echt
plädieren würde ein
realistischerer Blick auf die
Dinge wenn du sagst Menschen die vom
hungertd bedroht sind ich ich war oft
bei solchen Leuten in in so alia z.B
weißt du wenn du dort mit einem armen
Nomaden sprichst dessen letzte drei
Ziegen gerade noch am Leben sind und
dessen Kamel irgendwann in den Tagen
davor einfach umgekippt ist weil es
selbst dem Kamel zu trocken war weil es
dort seit 3 Jahren am Stück oder auch 5
Jahre es gibt solche Gegenden und immer
mehr nicht mehr geregnet hat wenn du das
siehst dann verstehst Du dass da ein
Leben nicht mehr möglich ist dann sitzen
diese beiden Armen Menschen diese Eltern
Mitte 30 sehen aus wie Ende 50 vom Leben
wirklich gezeichnet die Essen einmal am
Tag und das Frühstück besteht aus ein
bisschen Ziegenmilch mit ihren sieben
Kindern so diese Leute werden niemals
das Geld für eine Flucht nach Europa
aufbringen diese Leute kommen von dort
nicht weg denen muss man wirklich vor
Ort helfen und die sind wirklich
unmittelbar vom Hungertod bedroht ne
und deswegen die die nicht ich sage das
sondern Menschen die sich damit
beschäftigen berufsmäßig die sagen ein
großer Teil der Migration nach Europas
sind Menschen die suchen ein besseres
Leben wenn man jetzt sagt wir müssen das
natürlich unterscheiden und
differenzieren und sagen wir müssen wir
ganz ganz ganz unbedingt helfen und W
müssen wir nicht helfen wie sehe das aus
ja
eine adäquate Bewertung der Menschen
vorzunehmen die da übers Mittelmeer
gekommen sind wie viel Personal bräuchte
man dafür wo würde das stattfinden wo
würden die Leute solangee untergebracht
wer würde das finanzieren also wir reden
über über lauter Dinge von denen wir
ganz genau wissen die gehen nicht genau
tatsächlich kommen die da an kommen dann
quasi an so Sammelstellen ja dann wird
bei ganz vielen entschieden hör mal wir
sehen hier aber keine akute politische
Verfolgung und du kommst auch aus dem
Land wo gar nicht so viele hungern und
so weiter so und dann wird das der
Asylantrag und alles dann auch nicht
genehmigt und so weiter ja meistens ist
das ja in Italien und dann bleiben die
in Italien ja oder oder gehen weiter
nach Deutschland und faktis oder oder
gehen weiter aber sehr viele bleiben
aber die äh spannende Frage ist warum
ist das so und die einfache Antwort ist
weil es anders nicht geht ja die meisten
Länder nehmen die Menschen nicht zurück
W müsstest du die Rückführung
organisieren also so schiffechatern auf
denen die Leute zurückgebracht werden ja
und wenn du kommst jetzt also auf von
der Elfenbeinküste dann wirst du erstmal
nach Tunesien gebracht dann müsstest du
von Tunesien wieder organisieren dass
die Leute nicht in Tunesien bleiben und
mit dem nächsten schlepperschiff kommen
wer und wo soll das jemals machen genau
und deswegen glaube ich dass wir
Stichwort realistischer Blick auf die
Dinge man muss sozusagen immer wieder
versuchen die die die Dinge ein bisschen
einzuordnen ja du könntest sagen im
Moment sind z.B 4 Millionen Menschen
ungefähr je nach Lesart im Bürgergeld
oder in in Harz 4 bald Bürgergeld
zweieinhalb Millionen davon so
argumentiert Friedrich märz haben keinen
deutschen Pass kostet den Staat 40
Milliarden ist das ein Disaster oder ist
das möglicherweise etwas dass man
vielleicht auch anders betrachten kann
und dann wird's interessant wenn du
anfängst mal mit Ökonomen darüber zu
sprechen dann sagen die dir na ja
ähm das ist sehr viel Geld aber zunächst
mal muss man auch sagen diese
staatlichen Ausgaben für geflüchtete so
argumentiert jemand wie Marcel fratcher
z.B vom DIW der
sagte im im Jahr 2016 z.B haben die
staatlichen Ausgaben für geflüchtete das
Wirtschaftswachstum in Deutschland um
etwa
0,3% erhöht das ist interessant ne und
die das heißt die staatlichen Leistungen
für geflüchtet ist auch klar ne die
Leute kriegen das Geld wo geben Sie es
aus ja natürlich im eigenen Land das ist
quasi eine eine ein kleines
Konjunkturprogramm ja denn ultimativ
kommen sie dann deutschen Unternehmen
und Arbeitnehmern durch eine höhere
Nachfrage zugute ja und dann könnte man
natürlich sagen noch machen die die die
geflüchteten ja von 25 216 machen erst
einen kleinen Teil der Erwerbstätigen
aus aber langfristig glaubt jemand wie
fratcher z.B könnte die Integration der
geflüchteten die deutsche
Wirtschaftsleistung um
0,71% ungefähr erhöhen das sind
natürlich Zahlen glaube ich die sind
nicht so super super belastbar aber es
ist sehr interessant dass man eben merkt
ne da gibt's Leute die stellen sich die
Frage ist Zuwanderung unterm Strich äh
auch für die Wirtschaft gut oder ist sie
bilanziell negativ das ist die große und
da kommen wir da macht man einen Fass
auf ne über das man Jahre diskutieren
kann weil man kann das so rechnen und so
rechnen überlegt mal welche Faktoren man
alle einrechnen muss um die Frage zu
stellen ja ist Migration ökonomisch eine
eine gewinngeschichte oder eine
verlustgeschichte ja ja da müsst es ja
erstmal gucken okay als erstes siehst du
die ganzen transferleistungszahlung
Bürgergeld und was alles gezahlt wird
und so weiter und sist oh das belastet
enorm unsere Kassen so jetzt ist es
natürlich schon so dass ja nicht ganz
wenige ja und auch da gehen die
Expertenmeinung klein bisschen
auseinander der Menschen die da bei uns
angekommen sind dann doch irgendwann
meistens nicht sofort aber eher so nach
5 se Jahren etwa die Hälfte ja in
Arbeitsverhältnissen ist viele der Leute
die kommen gerade aus Afrika kommen sind
sehr jung das heißt sie sind sehr jung
und wenn sie dann vier oder 5 Jahre
später zu 50% bei uns im Arbeitsmarkt
integriert sind dann zahlen Sie in die
Rentenversicherung und in die
Krankenversicherung ein und das ist ganz
wichtig weil sie das rein theoretisch
wenn sie lange da bleiben und wenn sie
gut integriert sind bleiben sie
wahrscheinlich lange da das sehr lange
tun werden und natürlich einen sehr
wichtigen Beitrag dazu zahlen ja die
Babyboomer Generation ja über über Jahre
in ihrer Rente zu stützen mhm ja und in
der Krankenkasse noch wichtiger weil es
eben viele junge Menschen sind und nicht
eben alte Menschen die da im Regelfall
gekommen sind das heißt die Kosten die
Krankenkassen sehr wenig zahlen aber
ganz regulär dort ein das müsste man ja
in den volkswirtschaftlichen Nutzen
müssen man das ja alles einrechnen ne
und dann sieht man nicht nur eben das
was in Kosten sind sondern gleichzeitig
eben auch was an nutzen sind und ich
denke mir immer ich weiß dass bei diesen
Zahlen viel hin und her gerechnet wird
wie viele Arbeiten den nach welcher Zahl
und wie lange haben die vorher
Transferleistungen gekriegt und so und
da da da streiten sich die Gelehrten da
sind sich ja nicht zwei
Migrationsforscher und auch nicht zwei
Arbeitsmarktforscher wirklich einig also
richtig klar ist das nicht aber ich
würde andersrum mal formulieren man
stelle sich mal vor wir ziehen all die
Leute die aus anderen Ländern nach
Deutschland gekommen sind ja sowohl die
die Arbeiten wie die nicht arbeiten die
würden wir jetzt alle mal in einem
Gedankenexperiment alle
rausziehen dann würde bei uns die
Wirtschaft zusammenbrechen das wäre so
wir sind so abhängig davon im
Niedriglohnsektor ja gerade im Bereich
weniger qualifizierte Arbeit wenn du da
alles alles rausnimmst was allen
Menschen rausnimmst die den letzten 20
30 Jahren nach Deutschland gekommen sind
dann bricht ja nicht das Paradies aus
sondern dann haben wir einen eklatanten
Arbeitskräftemangel der in die viele
Millionen geht wir haben nicht genug
Leute mehr die in die Rentenversicherung
einzahlen in die Krankenversicherung und
so weiter und so weiter also bevor ich
die Frage mache ob die im jaah einen
volkswirtschaftlichen Gewinn oder einen
Verlust darstellen die Alternative dazu
alle rauszuziehen das wäre totales genau
ist ist ja auch völlig weltfremd würde
ja auch gar nicht geheni nur ein
Gedanken
nutzt es oder schadet es und dann kriegt
man unterm Strich kommt man niemals zu
dem Ergebnis dass es volkswirtschaftlich
unterm Strich schadet genau es gibt gibt
ja so ein paar interessante Punkte dabei
und du hast es gerade angesprochen
Richard es gibt Ökonomen die versuchen
das sogar zu berechnen die sagen pass
auf für jeden der kommt ja in den müssen
wir erstmal Geld investieren das ein
Investment es wird ganz ganz nüchtern
ein Investment volkswirtschaftlich
gesehen wann kommt der fiskalische Break
Even Point sozusagen ja an welcher
Stelle zahlt er dann sozusagen mehr ein
als er kostet es gibt gibt sogar eine
Zahl dazu
2031 ja wenn du dir mal die Leute
anschaust die z.B 2015 2016 gekommen
sind gerade 25 20116 weil das in der
deutschen Debatte so eine große Rolle
spielt gibt's ein paar sehr interessante
wirklich hard facts dazu die ich vor der
Beschäftigung jetzt auch für unsere
Folge hier so noch nicht kannte das
Durchschnitt sich Monatsgehalt der 2015
eingereisten liegt immer noch im
Niedriglohnbereich ja und da gibt's
umstrittene Zahlen Leute wie Rü Kopmann
z.B der sagt ja 43% Arbeiten maximal der
Rest hängt immer noch irgendwie in den
Transferleistungen fest das heißt der
der sieht das eher negativ andere sagen
ja mag sein aber wir wir machen da
gerade ein Investment wir bilden die aus
und irgendwann wird sich dieses
Investment lohnen das ist sozusagen
dieser Blick in die 2030er Jahre aber
interessant ist wo wo die die Arbeiten
wo die heute unterwegs sind
Niedriglohnbereich Durchschnittsgehalt
der 215 eingereisten ungefähr bei
2100 € brutto sagt man okay 2100 €
brutto das ist sozusagen fiskalisch für
die Summen die nötig sind ja wie viele
Steuern zahlen die Leute das ist jetzt
nicht das was das Land wirklich
voranbringt wenn man sagt wir müssen
gigantische Summen in den nächsten
Jahrzehten aber was die Wirtschaft den
Schwung hält das die Leute alle haben
genau und wer das verdient trägt
jährlich immerhin zu 11000 € für Steuern
und Abgaben bei ja das ist also auch
umgekehrt keine unerhebliche Summe das
heißt wir können davon profitieren wenn
Menschen auch im Niedriglohnbereich
arbeiten und dann gibt's eine sehr
interessante Beobachtung von den
Menschen die seit 2015 da sind das sagt
Brücker z.B a ein sehr renommierter
Migrationsforscher Arbeiten 70% als
Fachkräfte nur noch 30% als sogenannte
Helferinnen und Helfer das heißt die
Leute steigen langsam auf und da kommt
kopmz und sagt natürlich die Leute
steigen auf die hängen sich richtig rein
die strengen sich an also die die es
wollen aber es kommen neue hinzu und
dann kann man natürlich sagen eine
bestimmte Gruppe von Flüchtlingen die an
einem bestimmten Datum eingereist ist
die zahlt irgendwann so viele Steuern
dass die die Ausgaben gedeckt sind und
dass es vielleicht sogar positiv ist ein
quasi ein Gewinn Kopmann sagt aber wenn
man alle Flüchtlinge zusammen betrachtet
bleibt es im Moment zumindest bei einem
klaren Minus und zwar soange wie wir
diese irreguläre Migration nicht in den
Griff kriegen und ich glaube das ist
genau das Gefühl dass ganz viele da
draußen das verstehen die das verstehen
die ganz genau auch diesen Satz ne
irreguläre Migration in den Griff
kriegen wer ist denn dagegen da sind
alle für so aber wie na das das ist erst
mittlerweile ist das basiskonsens so von
von links bis rechts in der deutschen
Politik aber die Frage ja ja aber die
Frage des wie ist überhaupt nicht GT und
alles was wir jetzt an neuen an neuen
Lösungen haben ja also was europäisch
oder national oder so verabschiedet wird
das sind doch zahnlose Tiger ja ja da
kommen wir wieder
wieder bei meinen beii da sind wir
wieder genau bei
meinen Überlegungen wie ist das die
Leute landen in Italien an und dann wie
so was machen wir dann genau das ist das
funktioniert alles nicht wenn du dir die
Zahlen anschaust ja und sagt wir müssen
jetzt ein wahnsinnsanstrengung machen um
Leute wirklich in nennenswerter Zahl
abzuschieben stellst du fest es geht am
Ende um ein paar Hundert oder ein paar
tausend Menschen die wir zusätzlich
abschieben das ist nichts im Vergleich
zu dem was allein in diesem Jahr an an
an Menschen neu in dieses Land gekommen
ist ja werden deutlich über 300 000 sein
da haben wir über die Ukrainer noch gar
nicht gesprochen deswegen sagen Leute
wie z.B auch auch daaveder kobmann sag
pass auf die Idee der sicheren
Drittländer lass uns die doch über
Europa hinausdenken lass uns doch
überlegen was ist mit Senegal was ist
mit Ghana was ist mit Ruanda
beispielsweise das sind alles keine
perfekten Demokratien unseres Zuschnitts
vielleicht das ja einer der Gründe z.B
warum das Oberste Gericht in
Großbritannien auch den ersten Flug nach
Ruanda es war ja genau diese Idee Leute
nach Ruanda abzusie
die Dänen haben etwas ähnliches im
Hinterkopf warum das gestoppt worden ist
weil man sagt in Ruanda können wir nicht
für einen faires rechtsstaatliches
Verfahren garantieren das heißt aber
nicht und das das Interessante daran an
dieser Idee das heißt ja nicht dass man
das nicht dort etablieren kann wäre es
vielleicht eine Idee zu sagen pass auf
wir wir ermöglichen Menschen und damit
ist dann auch dieses schleuserbsiness
ein für alle mal tot damit ist dann
diese diese diese gefährliche Überfahrt
übers mittelmeertd wir möglichen Leuten
legale Wege rein nach Europa und diese
diese Verfahren machen wir aber in
Ruanda in Ghana in Ruanda noch mal dazu
gesagt relativ wenig Leute zu uns kommen
ne weil es sowas ist wie die Schweiz
Afrika ne ich weiß aber es muss
sozusagen die Möglichkeit für legale
Wege geben und ich glaube das das könnte
so ein Ansatz sein um um auch diesen
Zynismus da mal rauszubringen noch mal
ich find's so gruselig wir wir wir wir
sagen pass auf ihr ihr macht was immer
da passiert ihr verdurstet am Rande der
Wüste es gibt grauenvolle Bilder dazu W
Menschen wirklich nach dem letzten
Tropfen Wasser dann einfach ohnmächtig
im im im Sand irgendwo in Mali
zusammensinken und sich nie wieder
bewegen junge Leute ist grauenvoll ja
das nehmen wir alles in Kauf dann dann
wenn du es bis dahin geschafft h dann an
die tunesische Küste oder libische Küste
dann noch mal in dieses fürchterliche
Boot rein okay gut gut da sterben auch
Menschen aber die die es dann packen
denen sagen wir dann okay du kriegst
jetzt bei uns ein ordentliches Verfahren
sorry das das ist zynisch und und das
ist ein ein ein grauenvolles ein
Wettlauf den wir da Starten von dem ich
immer sagen würde das ver dich richtig
wir müssen wir müssten quasi also auf
das eine habe ich verstanden wir machen
Anwendungsprogramme in den jeweiligen
Ländern ja dass die Leute also nicht
diese diese gefährliche Wüsten und
schlöpperreise da und und
mittelmeerüberfahrt machen müssen
sondern die können sich quasi bewerben
ja und dann guckt man sich die die Leute
aus wo man sagt die kann man gebrauchen
die müssen jetzt gar keinen
hochqualifizierten sein die müssen
einfach nur n Eindruck machen we alles
brauchen W Menschen die was wollen vom
Leben das ist der Punkt aber vor einer
Sache hätte ich dann Angst weil das
klingt ja jetzt erstmal gut ne dann
könnte man sagen jetzt muss sich keiner
mehr auf den Weg machen ne wie wie wie
wie wird das schleppernetzwerk
ausgetrocknet indem es keine Leute mehr
gibt die sie brauchen ja also wil man
sagen kann man kann ja auch legal
einreisen auch Frauen haben dann eine
Chance ja weil Frauen riskieren noch
unendlich viel mehr wenn Sie diesen Weg
auf sich nehmen ja ein Problem gibt es
die Gefahr des braindrains weil sehr
viele Leute die die Möglichkeit haben
auch bei uns in gute und qualifiziertere
Berufe und so weiter zu kommen die haben
dann vielleicht auch ein starkes Motiv
ein Land indem sie nur einen Bruchteil
von dem was sie
dort ich ich habe nicht gesagt das ist
so ich den Einspruch möchte ich auch
gerne hören ich möchte von dir jetzt ein
richtig gutes Argument ja warum man
sagen kann wir nehmen den nicht die
besten Arbeiter weg ich habe zwei ich
hätte zwei Argumente richer das eine ist
Demografie äh Bevölkerungswachstum wenn
du dir die die Wachstumsraten allein z.B
in Nigeria anguckst ähm wir beide haben
schon mal drüber geredet ne wenn wenn
ein Land zunehmend zu Wohlstand kommt
dann dann sinkt die Geburtenrate das
heißt diese Projektion Diemer sagen
allein Nigeria wird am Ende des
Jahrhunderts ungefähr so viele Menschen
haben wie ganz Europa das wird aller
Wahrscheinlichkeit so nicht eintreten
genau nichts desto weniger haben die
diese Länder ein unglaubliches
Bevölkerungswachstum sehr viele junge
Menschen das ist das eine das zweite
Land das mir immer den Sinn kommt wenn
wir über Braindrain ja wir verlieren
sozusagen die besten sprechen besten
Leute genau ist Polen wenn Du Dir mal
die polnische ervolksgeschichte anguckst
ist
beeindruckend ich war kürzlich gerade
wieder in Polen wenn man durch Polen
fährt der der Spirit der Polen was die
Leisten wie fleißig die sind mit welchem
unerschütterlichen Optimismus die dieses
Land aufgebaut haben ist umso
beeindruckender wenn man weiß dass kurz
nach dem Mauerfall wenn du dich
erinnerst englische Oligarchen brauchten
und Großgrundbesitzer brauchten billige
Arbeitskräfte um ihre 25 stöckigen
Londoner Willen auch unterirdisch und so
weiter zu bauen ihre Pools 100 m unter
der Erde einzubauen ihre
Wellnessbereiche weil in London darf sie
ja nicht unendlich nach oben bauen das
Schwimmbad aufs Dach also baut man es
einfach tief in die Londoner Erde rein
so dafür brauchten die polnische
Handwerker und diese polnischen
Handwerker aber auch Servicekräfte wenn
du dich erinnerst in London bis heute
wenn du in London irgendwo im Restaurant
in der in der Bar unterwegs bist also
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dort jemanden aus
Polen zu treffen der dir deine deine
clubcoha bringt ja die ist extrem groß
und trotzdem haben die Polen trotz
dieses brainrains wenn man so will haben
es die Polen geschafft zu Hause richtig
was auf die Beine zu stellen das hat
auch damit zu tun dass mit dem vielen
Geld das dann zurücküberwiesen worden
ist genau haben sie dort Wirtschaft
angekurbelt in Afrika das gleiche was
wir an Entwicklungsgeldern bezahlen ist
ein Bruchteil dessen was afrikanische
Migranten z.B jedes Jahr aus eigener
Tasche zurücküberweisen in ihre Länder
ist ein Bruchteil davon viel viel mehr
also ich ich hab so ein gedanklichen
Kompromiss let ged das ist der Grund
warum dann auch viele das hast du auch
in Polen gesehen viele gehen dann
irgendwann auch wieder zurück das ist
die Entwicklung die dann dort
stattfindet und dann ist man doch häufig
auch wieder lieber zu Hause das ist das
ist der Zirkelschluss aber vielleicht
macht man es ganz einfach so dass man
beim anwerben bestimmte Berufsgruppen
hat wo man sagt die stehen h auf der
Liste die wollen wir jetzt nicht haben
z.B Ärzte oder so ja die ganz dringend
in den Ländern gebraucht werden dass wir
denen die nicht abwerben und sagen bei
uns kannst natürlich vierfache verdienen
mhm also vielleicht ein bisschen
sensibel darauf gucken wen man anwirbt
und wen nicht besonders schwierig ist ja
auch nicht besonders schwierig aber
ansonsten ist das natürlich äh die große
Frage warum gibt's das eigentlich nicht
im ganz großen Stil also der das das
qualifizierte Anwerben von
Arbeitskräften in Ländern südlich der
Sahara ich meine sind wir uns eigentlich
im kan darüber wie weltweit die
Situation aussieht dann ist immer so
diese Idee in Asien irgendwo gibt's die
oder in Indien gibt's die irgendwo oder
in Südkorea also China
südkorea Japan sowieso viele Länder
Asiens kämpfen selber mit gewaltigen
demografischen Problemen das heißt die
brauchen ihre eigenen Leute und die tun
sehr viel dafür Stichwort
Spitzensteuersatz um sie genau dort zu
halten wo sie schon sind und der
deutsche Spitzensteuersatz ist nicht
dazu angetan um diese topfachkräfte
diese topperformer hierher zu zu kriegen
auf gar keinen Fall über das deutsche
Wetter in dem Zusammenhang noch gar
nicht gesprochen so und das andere ist
diese Vorstellung da gibt's da draußen
irgendwo den den den den den Top ier und
der träumt Tag und Nacht davon jetzt
endlich mal weiß ich nicht nach nach
nach nach nach Hamburg oder Paderborn
oder ostnerabück oder wohin auch immer
zu kommen so ist das nicht das den gibt
es nicht deswegen denke ich immer lass
uns doch mit den Leuten wirklich
ernsthaft arbeiten die hier sind wie
kann es denn sein dass die
arbeitsmarktbeteiligung in anderen
Ländern USA oder auch in Großbritannien
oder auch z.B in den Niederlanden in den
Niederlanden arbeiten 50% der Ukrainer
die Dorin geflohen sind bei uns nur 20
warum warum ist das weil die bei uns in
Schulungen sind und in Ruhe die Sprache
lern das mag zutreffend sein aber ich
glaube sehr an an den dänischen
Grundsatz die Dänen sagen nee pass auf
wer neu in unser Land kommt geht sofort
arbeiten so schnell wie möglich weil
genau dort am Arbeits Platz findet
Integration statt da findet Spracherwerb
statt
natürlich das das ist der Punkt und da
wirst du auch Teil dieser Gesellschaft
und da sind wir beim letzten Punkt und
das hat dieser Tage jemand mal mal
beschrieben der der sich offensichtlich
sehr gut auskennt in diesem in diesem
ganzen Bereich der der sagte von so
einer Denkfabrik den Namen leider nicht
parat der sagte wir träumen von der vier
Tage Woche und dem Beamtentum jetzt
zugespitzt so hat er das beschrieben
ja junge Migranten nicht junge Migranten
haben eine Rechnung offen mit dem Leben
und wenn man z.B mit
investmentbankkerern spricht deutschen
investmentber dann sagen die dir na pass
auf also in meiner Investmentabteilung
da wo es richtig zur Sache geht wo man
wahnsinnig leisten und abliefern muss wo
man auch ein hohes Risiko gehen muss wo
man sehr belastbar sein muss ich ohne
junge Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
könnte mein Laden hier zuachchen die
sind viel risikobereiter die gehen viel
mehr in die Vollen als fast alle anderen
das heißt ein ein anderer Spirit und er
sagt das was Amerika bis heute so
unglaublich stark macht ist genau dieser
dieser dieser Spirit dieser diese diese
diese Leidenschaft der der der
Einwanderer die immer noch in so großer
Zahl ins Land kommen und immer wieder
neue Ideen neue Impulse setzen die
dieses Land am Ende so groß gemacht
haben und diese Kräfte von denen würde
ich sagen da sind wir nicht gut darin
diese Kräfte wirklich zu entfesselnm da
denken wir vielleicht auch einfach viel
zu bürokratisch und vielleicht auch in
in in in Mustern die mehr mit der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland zu tun haben als mit der
Lösung aktueller Probleme ich möchte
ganz zum Schluss fragen wenn das jetzt
ein politisches Programm würde worüber
wir hier geredet haben ja dann hätte das
ja die Kernaussage wir trocknen die
illegale Migration dadurch aus dass wir
die legale Migration qualifizierter und
transparenter genau ne das wäre ja quasi
das Programm glaubst du dass eine
politische Partei damit in Deutschland
Wahlkämpfe gewinnen könnte ja ich glaube
ja oder glaubst du was glaubst du dass
es mehr Menschen gibt die sagt ja das
ist doch hier tatsächlich vielleicht
irgendwie also Lösung ist ja immer ein
einfaches Wort ne aber das hilft uns
weiter und es gibt andere Leute sagen
wie jetzt ge fahren wir da nach Guinea
und die Elfenbeinküste und
nach Nigeria ja und und holen jetzt noch
ganz bewusst ganz viele Menschen aus
diesem Land zu uns das das würde doch
wahrscheinlich der der AFD am Ende dann
wieder Auftrieb geben weil ein
Hauptgrund gegen Migration ne sind ja
also viele Leute die stark gegen
Migration sind die beschäftigen sich
jetzt nicht mit ökonomischen
Zusammenhängen über die wir uns hier die
Köpfe heiß geredet haben ja Beiträge zu
Krankenversicherung und
Rentenversicherung und demografischer
Faktor die haben einfach ein Unbehagen
ja wenn Sie viele Menschen mit anderer
Hautfarbe auf der Straße sehen
fällt hier noch irgendetwas ein äh wie
du diese Menschen überzeugen würdest
also in Thüringen dort wo der erste AFD
Landrat gewählt worden ist das ist ein
Landstrich der lebt genau mit diesem
demographischen Problem im riesigen
Fachkräftemangel und der wird sich in
den nächsten Jahren weiter verschärfen
bin sehr gespannt was dieser AFD Landrat
in Leuten dauerhaft sagen wird wo denn
der Wohlstand in Ihrer Region herkommt
zweiter Punkt der größte
ähm Batteriehersteller der Welt catl
Chinesen betreiben ein Werk in äh
Thüringen äh das das wichtigste Werk in
Europa die europaniederlassung von denen
äh die bauen dort richtige machen dort
richtig Zellfertigung 400 chinesische
Fachkräfte bringen dort deutschen
mittlerweile bei wie man Batterien baut
also das heißt das nau läuft da
plötzlich in die andere Richtung
diese Leute
werden deutsche ausbilden das ist ein
ein ein wie soll man sagen ein ein
Sammelbecken von verschiedenen Nationen
und Kulturen ich hab mit dem mit dem
Chef mit Herrn Hüttenrauch mal darüber
gesprochen sehr interessanter Mann der
kann dir das genau erklären der sagt bei
mir arbeiten ich glaube 40 Nationen
Menschen aus der ganzen Welt das heißt
darauf will ich hinaus in vielen Teilen
der Wirtschaft ist das längst Realität
was wir uns ja genau in einer idealen
Welt so vorstellen und ich ich glaube
dass wir eben beides brauchen wir wir
brauchen auf der einen Seite Ordnung in
diesem System die Idee dieses
sogenannten Ruanda Modells und Rwanda
steht ja nur sozusagen ja es ist ist ein
Platzhalter wenn man so will die Idee
ist ja nicht dass alle Leute nach Ruanda
gehen die Idee ist ja dass den Leuten
klar wird pass auf meine Flucht endet in
Ruanda ich muss dort versuchen einen
meinen guten Weg zu machen um nach
Europa zu kommen weiter darüber hinaus
geht es nicht den illegalen Weg zu uns
gibt es nicht mehr ich erinnere nur in
dem Zusammenhang daran die australer
haben es so gemacht die haben Leute die
illegal ins Land gekommen sind auf einer
winzigen Pazifikinsel ausgesetzt halb so
groß wie sült und haben sie dort ihr
Asylverfahren machen lassen aber
gleichzeitig hat Australien und das
wusste ich nicht Australien hat ein sehr
hohes Kontingent für Fachkräfte
zuuwanderung das heißt es gibt einen
legal Weg rein nach Australien aber so
gut wie kann illegal me das hat für die
australer super funktioniert ich kenne
die ganzen Gegenargumente wir sind nicht
Australien wir haben nicht tausende
Kilometer Wasser dazwischen und so
weiter ich glaube es braucht eben das
beides auf der einen Seite die Vision
wie es gehen könnte und auf der anderen
Seite aber auch endlich dass das den den
ernsthaft erkennbaren politischen Willen
Ordnung in diese sogenannte irreguläre
Migration reinzubringen und wenn das
geht glaube ich sind Menschen zu ganz
ganz vielen bereit ja aber Ordnung und
das ist das was das was wir hier gerade
besprechen unterscheidet von dem was ich
in erster Linie aus dem politischen
Debatten höre Ordnung durch proaktives
Handeln genau und nicht Ordnung durch
reaktives handeln wenn es eigentlich
sowieso zu spät ist genau das Richard
dank dir sehr spannender Austausch ja
danke dan ja mach gut bis dahin tschüss
Markus
Ciao eine Produktion von 2 und podstars
bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF